Speaker 1: Well, folks, it finally got me.
I have covered those of you who follow me
on social media. I already know many of
you sending well-wishes. A few of you
sending horrible messages. And you were
summarily blocked, I guess I should say.
I have to tell you that I had about a 28 ish hour
period where I was as sick as I remember being
in my entire life. And everybody in the house has
it. My girlfriend has it. The little baby has it.
Fortunately, my daughter actually seems to be
having the easiest go of it. And, you know,
it's interesting because on the Thursday and
Friday show, I felt as I spoke that I had a
little something in my voice that didn't sound
quite right. And surprisingly, no one emailed
me about it. I often get emails, you know, from
from many of the moms in the audience who say,
David, I've been around sick kids enough to know
you didn't sound quite right on today's show or
yesterday. And sometimes they're not even
right. But nobody said anything to me about
my voice. Thursday, Friday and later Thursday,
about 5:00. We were already done producing the
Friday show as well. I started just not feeling
quite right. I didn't really have a sore throat,
but it didn't feel completely right and I didn't
really I didn't have a cough, but I felt just like
a little tickle somewhere in my chest. And then
at a certain point you get that revelation where
you you say to yourself, Sir, and that's how I
talk to myself. My internal dialog is extremely
polite and formal. I said to myself, Sir, I think
I may have a fever. And indeed I had like 99. And
then I woke up in the middle of the night late
Thursday with like a 101 or 100.5 fever. And
basically from the middle of the night, early
Friday until later in the afternoon, Saturday,
it is as sick as I remember being in my life. And
it's not that my fever was that high. It didn't
ever get above 101. But just the most painful.
I don't know how to describe it. Just painful.
Fever. Malaise. One of the worst headaches I've
ever had and just really horrible. And then I,
you know, I quite literally couldn't do anything.
I watched World Cup games and thankfully Argentina
won on Saturday. It would have been extremely,
you know, adding insult to injury to see Argentina
lose while having COVID. And it was very clear,
you know, I had an insane sweating episode and
then my fever seemed to break and I have been
feeling better and better. The cold came in
after like I hadn't really no cold symptoms at
first. And then later I started to get stuffed
up. I got a bunch of Trump Sudafed, which is why
I'm all hopped up on it right now. That's a joke,
by the way. No, but I did use yesterday. I use
DayQuil to to manage the daytime congestion and.
Long story short, it morphed into a cold after the
really horrible period. And then my daughter got
the fever. And then my girlfriend and it's
all rotating and it's crazy. And I learned
about the existence of Tylenol suppositories
for babies that's probably we probably need
a bonus show episode on Tylenol suppositories
will skip that for today. But long story short,
I'm not unpack slow vid or Paxil of
it. And the reason is my doctor said
your health status and the severity of the
symptoms don't really warrant it. And there's
some not great side effects sometimes with the
Paxil, Ovid and or Paxil of it, I don't know.
Everybody says it a different way. It's like
caramel. Caramel, I don't know the Paxil. David
And also you can get this rebound COVID after 7 to
10 days, it'll get rid of your symptoms quick, but
then 7 to 10 days later, you could have a rebound
and then you can't take the Paxil of it. And so
then you kind of have to just suffer through it.
So we made the decision, which seemed like the
obvious one, not to take that and let's hope it's
just a recovery from here. So those of you who are
watching know I'm wearing 12 masks today. Now I'm
by myself in a studio, so I'm not wearing a mask.
And that that would be a strange thing to do on
the show. But we're following all the protocols
and doing doing everything. And hopefully my
hope is that in another 48 hours, everybody in
the house will be out of the woods. Now, in terms
of vaccines. Oh, David, are people on Twitter, are
you vaccinated, aren't you? I guess the vaccine
doesn't do anything. Listen, I have no idea the
the belief there's two possibilities, right? I
got as sick as I did because the vaccine didn't
help me in any way or I didn't get even sicker,
potentially risking hospitalization. I don't
know. Because I was fully vaccinated, including
with the American Bivalent vaccine, which I got.
I guess it was a couple of months ago. So I don't
know, we it's I only have myself as a test case on
that. I don't know whether or how much sicker
I would have been without it. But that's been
that's been the last, I guess, 70 to
96 hours or something like that. So,
um, let's get into the show. There's so much
to talk about. I'm glad to be here. And quite
frankly, I have nothing else to do because I'm
not doing anything. So let's get right into it.